you mentioned baby x uh so there's this
young consciousness
coming to be
came from a cell it like
like that whole thing doesn't even makes
it came from dna yeah and then there's
this baby computer it just like grows
and grows and grows and grows and now
there's a conscious being with extremely
impressive cognitive capabilities
with uh have you met him yes yeah yeah
he's actually really smart he's really
smart yeah he's weird
yeah baby he doesn't i don't i i haven't
i don't know a lot of other babies but
he's actually i don't know with babies
often but this baby was very impressive
he does a lot of pranks and stuff
oh so he's like he'll like like give you
a treat and then take it away and laugh
and like stuff like that so he's like a
chess player uh
so
here's a
cognitive sort of there's a computer
being programmed he's taken in the
environment interacting with a specific
set of humans
uh how would you first of all what what
is it what let me ask
i want to ask how do you program this
computer
and also how do you make sense of that
there's a conscious being right there um
that wasn't there before it's giving me
a lot of crisis thoughts i'm thinking
really i think that's part of the reason
it's like i'm struggling to focus on
art and stuff right now because baby x
is becoming
conscious and like my
it's just reorienting my brain like my
brain is suddenly totally shifting of
like oh [ __ ] like the way we
raise children like
like i hate
all the baby books and everything i hate
them like they're all the art is so bad
and like like all the stuff
everything about all the aesthetics and
like i'm just like ah like this is so
the programming languages we're using to
program these baby computers isn't good
yeah like i i'm thinking and i i not
that i have like good answers or know
what you know what to do but um
i'm just thinking really
really hard about it i
uh we we recently watched uh totoro with
him studio jimmy yeah um and
it's just like a fantastic film and he
like responded to i know you're not
supposed to show baby screens too much
but like
i think it's the
most sort of like
i feel like it's the highest art baby
content like it's it's it it it really
speaks there's almost no
talking in it it's really simple
although all the dialogue is super super
super simple
you know and it's it's like an a one to
three year old can like really connect
with it like it feels like it's almost
aimed at like a one to three-year-old um
but it's like great art and it's so
imaginative and it's so beautiful and um
like the first time i showed it to him
he was just like so invested in it
unlike i've ever unlike anything else
i'd ever shown him like he was just like
crying when they cry and laughing when
they laughed like just like having this
roller coaster of like emotions like and
he learned a bunch of words like he was
and he started saying totoro and started
just saying all this stuff after
watching totoro and
he wants to watch it all the time and i
was like man
why isn't there an industry of this like
why aren't our best artists
focusing on making art
like for
the birth of consciousness like and and
that's one of the things i've been
thinking i really want to start doing
you know i don't want to speak before i
do things too much but like like i
i'm just like
ages one to three like
we should be putting so much effort into
that and the other thing about totoro is
it's like um it's like better for the
environment because adults love totoro
it's such good art that everyone loves
it like i still have all my old totoro
merch from when i was a kid like i
literally have the most ragged
old totoro merch
um like everybody loves it everybody
keeps it it's like
why does
the art we have for babies
need to
suck and then and be
not accessible to adults and then just
be thrown out when
um
you know they age out of it like it's
like i i i i don't know i i'm i don't
have like a fully formed thought here
but this is just something i've been
thinking about a lot is like how do we
like
how do we have more totoro esque content
like how do we have more content like
this that like
is universal and everybody loves but is
like
really geared to an emerging
consciousness emerging consciousness in
the first like three years of life that
so much turmoil so much evolution of
mind is happening
it seems like a crucial time would you
say
to make it not suck
do you think of
basically treating a child
like they have the capacity to have the
brilliance of an adult or even beyond
that is that how you think of that mind
or no because they still
they like it when you talk
weird and stuff like they respond better
to
because even they can imitate better
when your voice is higher like people
say like to ah don't do baby talk but
it's like when your voice is higher it's
closer to something they can imitate so
they like
like the baby talk actually kind of
works like it helps them learn to
communicate i found it to be more
effective with learning words and stuff
but like
you're not speaking i'm not like you're
speaking down to them like yeah do you
do do they have the capacity to
understand really difficult concepts you
know just in a very difficult different
way like an emotional intelligence about
something
deep within
oh yeah no like if x hurts like if x
bites me really hard and i'm like ow
he like he gets he's sad
he's he's like sad if he hurts me by
accident yeah which he's huge so he
hurts me a lot
uh yeah that's so interesting that that
that that mind emerges and and he and
children don't really have memory of
that time so he can't even have a
conversation with them about it yeah so
they don't have a memory of this time
because like think about like
i mean with our
youngest baby like it's like
i'm like have you read the sci-fi
short story i have no mouth but i'm a
scream
good title no
oh man i mean you should read that
uh that's that's scream that it's
i i hate getting into this roko's
basilisk [ __ ] it's kind of a story about
the um about like um
uh
an ai that's like torturing someone in
eternity and they have like no body the
way they describe it it sort of sounds
like what it feels like like being a
baby like you're conscious and you're
just getting inputs from everywhere and
you're you have no muscles and you're
like jelly and you like can't move and
you try to like communicate but you
can't communicate and we're and like
you're just like
in this like hell state i think it's
good we can't remember that
like
my little baby is just exiting that like
she's starting to like get muscles and
have more like autonomy but like
watching her go through the opening
phase i was like
i was like this does not seem good
oh you think it's kind of like i think
it sucks i think it might be really
like violent mentally violent
psychologically violent consciousness
emerging i think is is a very violent
thing
i think it's possible that we all carry
quite a bit of trauma from it that we
don't i i think that would be a good
thing to study because i think if
i think addressing that trauma
like i think that might be oh you mean
like echoes of it are still there in the
shadows i think it's gotta be i i feel
this this help the helplessness
the the like existential and that like
fear of being in like an unknown place
bombarded with inputs and being
completely helpless like that's got to
be somewhere deep in your brain and that
can't be good for you
you